Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Korean Comedy Drama film
called “Granny's Got Talent.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The protagonist of the movie is an old woman known
as Granny. She has been living in prison for the
past few decades for not paying her debts. A day
before getting out, she boasts about her sons’
achievements to her cellmates. Her older son works
in a prestigious company while her younger one is
a musician. Despite both of them having different
fathers, they are both diligent like her. Granny
gets out of the prison the next day but no one
comes to pick her up. While she is in a subway,
she witnesses a middle-aged man harassing a young
girl. Since no one else intervenes, she speaks up
for the girl and cusses the man. The entire crowd
is stunned to hear her vocabulary of curse words.
At the next stop, she kicks the man out. Granny’s
elder son is named Seung-hyeon. He works an
average job at a prestigious company and is always
disrespected by his co-workers. When Seung-hyeon
was little, Granny’s debt collectors used to
yell at him because of her. On being sentenced
to prison, she left him in an orphanage, because
of which he has hated her his entire life.
Seung-hyeon lives with his wealthy in-laws
and has been working hard to someday buy a
house of his own and move with his wife and
son. Somewhere else, a media company thinks
of an exciting television program to bring in
revenue. They organize a non censored cursing
competition. The only problem is that they are
short on participants. PD Yang and her associate
are given the responsibility to look for the
top insulters of the city. Granny’s younger son,
Joo-hyeon is unemployed and lives off his wife’s
income. They welcome Granny in their house,
mostly because she hands his wife a bundle of
money as a gift. Granny finds out that her elder
son is living with his in-laws. She knows that he
dislikes her but still wants to meet him. So, pays
a man to land her the job as a maid at his house.
The next day, she goes to his house for the first
time and is briefed about her job by the previous
maid. The maid also mentions that Seung-hyeon’s
mother-in-law wants the housemaid to be fluent
in English. Granny says a few English words to
make her believe she is in fact fluent.
Although it is difficult to work as a maid at
her age, she doesn’t mind as long as she gets to
see her son, daughter-in-law, and grandson. For
the past few days, PD Yang and her associate have
been looking for foul-mouthed people of the town.
They hear about Granny from someone and set
out to look for her. Granny finally meets
Seung-hyeon but he isn’t happy to see her. He
ignores her entirely and gets in a car with the
chairman of his company and his mother-in-law.
The chairman also sees Granny who reminds him
of a kind lady he had met when he was in prison.
The lady had stopped him from committing suicide
so he is always thankful to her. Granny cannot
sleep at night because of her son’s indifference
to her arrival. She walks to a nearby park
and screams profanities to no one. PD Yang,
who is also at the park hears her but cannot
find her in the dark. Starting the next day, she
and her associate stay at the park waiting for the
foul-mouthed old lady. The next day, Seung-hyeon’s
mother-in-law brings an English teacher to
test if Granny lied about her qualifications.
The teacher quickly catches up to her lie and
reveals she doesn’t know how to speak English.
The mother-in-law is furious and wants to fire
her, but Seung-hyeon’s wife insists they do
not need someone who speaks in English just to do
household work. When Granny returns home that day,
she hears Joo-hyeon and his wife arguing. It turns
out that he gambled away the money she had given
them. Joo-hyeon and Granny go to the park where
reveals that he needs a lot of money to pay off
his debt. Just then, PD Yang finds Granny and asks
her to be in their show. At first Granny declines
the offer. But PD Yang doesn't stop trying to
persuade her. Eventually, she agrees to do it
for the three hundred thousand dollar prize
money. Finally, the auditions for the swearing
competition take place. The judges dismiss most
of the contestants because they do not match their
standards. When it is Granny’s turn to audition,
she is blinded by the spotlight and cannot speak.
One of the judges makes fun of her for being old
which triggers her. She curses her heart out at
the judge and gets instantly selected.
Somewhere else, Seung-hyeon’s wife and his
mother-in-law go to meet the Chairman’s wife
to maintain their social status. While waiting
for her, they discuss Granny’s behavior and how
she lied about her qualifications. As they talk,
the mother-in-law also suggests the wife divorce
a loser like Seung-hyeon. They mistakenly leave
Granny’s CV with her picture on the table.
When the chairman's wife arrives a while later,
she recognizes Granny as an old friend who she
respects the most. It turns out that although
she is wealthy, she had once stolen Granny’s money
and was the reason that she had to leave her kids
and go to jail. She feels very sorry for Granny
and plans to meet her to ask for forgiveness.
At work when everyone is out, Granny
gets some alone time with her grandson
for the first time. She picks him up from the
bus stop and takes him to the park. The kid’s
parents are always busy so he is delighted to
finally have someone to play with. They spend
the entire day together playing and learning.
When his mother returns home, she sees that the
kid is silently eating food on his own. She
is impressed by Granny’s skills because it
has always been difficult for her to feed her son.
Granny teaches her a few tricks about parenting,
after which she decides not to fire her.
The next day, they shoot the first episode
of the cursing competition. Granny has to go
against several youngsters but she is confident
because no one is as good as her. She makes
some of them cry with only her words. One of
them even passes out not being able to handle the
profanities. She also goes against a beatboxer
who makes inappropriate hand gestures. Just when
everyone thinks she is about to lose this one, she
claps back with even filthier movements that make
the guy almost cry. At the end of the episode,
Granny gathers many fans around Korea. Because
of her, the program is a hit. The chairman’s
wife who has stolen money from the granny sees
her on TV and finds out where she lives.
While working at Seung-hyeon’s home, she makes
sure to try to reconnect with him. She also
discovers a photo album in his cabin with an old
picture of her. This makes her hope that her son
will eventually forgive her. One day, she meets
the Chairman's wife and her friend on the street.
The women beg for forgiveness for their deeds.
Although their mistake had caused Granny to be
separated from her children, she forgives them and
tells them that she doesn’t want the money back.
In the next episode of the cursing competition, a
lawyer is made to go against a girl. It is almost
impossible to win against the lawyer who uses his
knowledge of the constitution to argue. Meanwhile,
Granny goes against a rapper who freestyles
his diss. But after cursing at the audience
to yell louder and hyping them up, Granny wins
this round as well. The producer of the show
is over the moon after the broadcast. The ratings
have skyrocketed because of Granny. To stir more
drama, he sends people to find out about Granny’s
past so her opponents can use it to diss her.
One day, Granny is with Seung-hyeon’s wife
visiting the market when she sees a shopkeeper
hitting his wife. She calls him out for it and
throws profanities at him. The people around her
start to recognize her so she quickly walks back
to the house. Granny and Seung-hyeon’s wife start
to get along well. Moreover, Seung-hyeon’s
son treats her like his own grandmother,
even though he doesn’t know it. Seung-hyeon,
on the other hand, has finally gathered enough
money to buy a house. He asks his real estate
agent for a house with three bedrooms, just in
case Granny wants to stay with them. He, too, is
opening up to his mother. For the next episode,
Granny is made to go against the lawyer while
pretending to be his wife. She makes fun of the
size of his appendage, making everyone laugh. Her
jokes turn into memes which makes her even more
famous. She wins against the unbeatable
lawyer and reaches the final round.
The lawyer is enraged by the loss and humiliation
he had to face on national television. To take
revenge on Granny, he digs up her past and finds
out she abandoned her sons and is an ex-con. Soon,
the word goes around and the man Granny kicked out
of the train testifies against her on TV. As the
news spreads, random people join the bandwagon,
coming out with false accusations against her.
People find out that Seung-hyeon and Joo-hyeon
are her sons. Seung-hyeon’s colleague, who already
thought he was a loser, makes fun of him because
of his mother. This triggers the trauma that
Seung-hyeon has been suppressing his entire life.
Moreover, his mother-in-law also finds out about
his mother and blames him for bringing his ex-con
mother into their house. Taking the opportunity,
she declares that her daughter is divorcing him
soon. Granny gets on her knees and begs the woman
not to ruin her son’s life just because she is mad
at her. However, the mother-in-law kicks her out
of the house after insulting her. When Granny
returns home, Joo-hyeon is furious at her. He
hadn’t known that she had been working as a maid
at Seung-hyeon’s house. He hates the fact that his
mother favors his elder brother more than him.
The two get into a huge argument when suddenly,
Granny starts to cough uncontrollably.
Joo-hyeon and his wife go to the doctor and show
him the medicine that Granny takes, only to find
out that she has a weak heart and probably has had
a few heart attacks when she was in prison. That
night, Granny gets a call from Seung-hyeon’s wife
who informs her that he hasn’t returned home.
Granny goes to his work and asks his colleagues
about him but they too, have no answer. She
doesn’t agree to leave until they tell her where
he is which causes a huge fuss in the office. The
chairman notices this and comes out of his cabin.
He instantly recognizes Granny as the woman who
saved his life in prison. He kneels in front of
her in gratitude, surprising his employees. They
finally listen to Granny’s request and kindly tell
her that they haven’t seen Seung-hyeon since
the last day. Meanwhile, outside the studio,
a crowd has gathered to protest against the
cursing competition, claiming that it is immoral
for giving an ex-con a platform. The last episode
is about to begin but Granny hasn’t come to the
set. In the following scene, we see Seung-hyeon
in his car. Nothing in his life is going right
so he has decided to commit suicide. He
drives into a wall and falls unconscious.
In the meantime, Granny goes to the studio but is
clearly not ready for the last round. On top of
that, she has to go against another old woman
who hasn’t lost a single round till now. The
competition gets more difficult for Granny when it
is announced that they have to fight like a mother
and son. Her opponent goes as a son and insults
her. But when it is Granny's turn to speak,
she stays silent. A man from the audience throws
an egg to her face, humiliating her in front of
everyone. She speaks for the first time and claims
that everyone who is cursing at her right now is
right. Instead of insulting the opponent, Granny
explains how she has been a horrible mother to
her kids. At last, she breaks down crying and
says that she loves her children dearly. As she
gives the heartfelt speech, Seung-hyeon crawls
out of the car and is saved by people nearby.
Granny’s words inspire many people from around
the country. They start to yell profanities at
everything that has been bothering them in life.
Granny’s opponent goes silent and she finally
wins the competition. However, she vomits
blood and falls unconscious right after.
She is admitted to the hospital where
Seung-hyeon comes to see her and calls
her mom for the first time in decades. Granny is
now surrounded by her family who loves her dearly.
She soon gets well and comes out of the hospital
as a celebrity. The women who had stolen from her,
agree to return all the money with interest.
Seung-hyeon’s mother-in-law sees Granny’s
connections and apologizes to her. At the
end of the movie, she gets inside a car to
fly to America for heart surgery.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.